it's going to be back in New York the
first year of grad school this was my
neighborhood so if you need a watering
hole
I suggest waterfront Ale House second in
30th go there ale house there we go so
when the Russians about back then the
Soviets launched Sputnik it started the
biggest investment in what now cost 10
and the amount of Science in the u.s.
went skyward like one of those Wernher
von Braun rockets right and you know
nowadays satellites are part of our
everyday life and if you want to see how
many of those are out when I suggest
going here you can see like you know how
many of those each country has and you
can make kill them dance and you can see
all these satellites flying around and
you can find out which is what so this
is Hubble Space Telescope these guys
going like crazy the military in spite
you know keyhole satellites and this
busy strip here salts communication
satellites spying satellites then you
have you know the positioning GPS and
goes all the way to the ones that are
now circling around the moon and when
you know we speak about satellites for
regular uses they basically catch her
eye and spark our imagination right so
you see this one you say screw my balls
screw polar vortex and into vacation
somewhere warm like Lucy's right or you
see something like this and you say oh
reminds me for wicked acid trip I had in
college
and I should know a thing about you
about acid for one reason only
that's because I'm a chemist now if you
want to make acid in your kitchen you
need like six pounds of barley or rye
you need six you know cookie trays a
humidifier if you want to find out the
rest buy me beer and I'll tell you this
tragedy family recipe
my name is mosh
my last name is really hard to spell and
pronounced by native English speakers
as we've seen from the previous talk so
I was born in that country of Australia
so now you know that I speak five
languages and my mom thinks I'm very
smart now why would you use Python
scientific stack to analyze satellite
images well you know it's three we all
here for a reason and Python has very
rich you know ecosystem for you know
juice analysis but most of those are
basically bindings you know to see for
all those things and you know they're
there for a reason I mean Python is nice
but all image analysis lends itself to
being highly paralyzed you cannot run it
to GPUs and in that respect
you know Python is still way back but
you know it's free and what's best you
can you know get satellite data for free
nowadays the the biggest custodian of
satellite data is US Geological Survey
and they have you can download data
ranging back to 1920 s all the way to
the latest satellite that you know they
have in orbit that I'll briefly describe
now you know dealing with this date and
it's usually data set is around 1.7
gigabytes so it's not easy to distribute
also you are not allowed to distribute
yourself for people to analyze so best
way as you go to you know US Geological
Survey we register for free and you can
download what they call level one data
so that's basically very detailed data
that's you know you can download it
while sitting on our couch sipping
coffee and you can analyze it later
using your you know Python scientific
stack
so I'll be using Landsat 8 as our you
know example satellite and data that was
acquired by Landsat 8 it went up into
the skies last summer
it is predicted to last about five years
and it will you know but it's sheer
number it's 40 years of legacy for
Landsat satellites it's circling around
Earth every 99 minutes and it come back
to the same spot
it took image from every 16 days and its
orbit is in such way such angle and the
orbiting that it's what they call is
geosynchronous so that the orbit moves
by the same angle as the work as the
Earth spins around the Sun so it's
always the same position and angle in
respect to the Sun it's very important
because you know quantify your images at
not with same conditions and to get
those images your you know rays of light
have to go through the atmosphere and
now here in gray is where you have a
window to acquire data and in white is
everywhere where atmosphere basically
absorbs you light so there's nothing
coming through and you can see that the
top row of of bands is what is it
available with Landsat 8 and you can see
that most of the time we are in the you
know clear window except this band here
and this one suspiciously is smack down
in where you know the that must feel
strongly absorbs that and there for a
reason so let's go ahead and start
seeing what are all these bands that we
have available
so been one is what they call hopeful or
aerosol it's basically in little past
blue but you would call violet or UV and
it's there because this light if you're
you know scientific oriented these are
the wavelengths of the light so I mean
it's not really necessary for you to
know so with this you know coastal line
you can see it's basically the same as
the blue light but it enters the water a
bit deeper and it's also scattered more
about all the particles that are in the
air especially that you know the the
water that's kind of atomized and
floating in the air so it's very
important for the the oceanic ecosystem
now that the next three bands are what
they'll be really used to analyzing it's
you know red green and blue so I'll come
back to those a bit later
then the next one is near-infrared so
now this is getting into the area where
people mostly are not used to to this so
it's best you know you'll RGB what you
know but this bed is important because
it's very useful for analyzing plant
life plant life scatters this light more
effectively than anything else and it's
also telling you if the plants are alive
or dead so it's very useful for
agricultural data I'm doing this just to
show you you know how quickly or how
easy is to analyze this data it in real
time and this is what you would expect
it in its gray image now I'll go back
here to show you one thing that I told
you about RGB so here I think I have a
image of it was cold
King fire it was fired up as burning
this is Lake Tahoe here it was burning
this I think August and those big fires
and you can see that you know well not
really easily but this is all the smoke
coming out from fires and what's good
about you know having different bands
for you to choose from if some of these
bands can actually go to the smoke so
this is the the same image sorry this is
the different image this is the image of
LA I think yes this is the Malibu
so let's move to what I wanted to show
you
so then we have the the same image of
fire around Lake Tahoe but you can see
it's smoke is not visible there it's
because this particular band can
penetrate the smoke so it's really
useful for basically seeing through
what's not what cannot be seen by a
naked eye then eight is panchromatic so
it means the RGB s are collected at the
same time but stored as a you know by
can mine do a image and you can see now
here this band has the highest
resolution of all bands all previous
ones were at 30 meters per pixel this
one is at 15 and it's very important
when you want to you know analyze fine
details in your image now bent nine it
is the if you records that weird one
that was sitting down where the
atmosphere was absorbing so why the hell
would you know scientists put a band
there and it's for one reason and one
reason only it's for detecting you know
Cirrus or Cyrus clouds these clouds are
very high up there probably 30
kilometers up and they're not clouds
made out of gases these are actually ice
particles and they're within thin it's
really hard to spot them and for precise
measurements you need really to know
what is your light coming through and
reflect it back to account for all these
you know various things that can affect
your precise measurements and here let's
see
this is a snap taken over Paris and you
can see all the contrails from there you
know the busy airplane route and in the
contrails are also about the same height
you would get them from in the cirrus
clouds and this is making the the
scientists who analyze data their life
very easy bubble easier bends 10 and 11
there are if you now recall back you
know the the second group of bands in
that image that I showed you so they're
part of a different instrument all the
bands up to this one they come from all
D which is operational land imager oli
and others comes from turrets which is
thermal infrared system now here I'll
show you a bay in Nova Scotia and
unfortunately it's always a shame that
the details get lost here but you know
this is the land this is the ocean and
here you can see the currents which have
different temperatures coming from all
the glaciers melting and inter mixing
with warmer bay water you also have
another book if you go through though
you know process of Domonic data there
is very important text file that you
have there and it has older you know geo
data where it was collected let and
longitude of corners and all that stuff
it has the readings from older you know
different pixels in your two images this
is also an advancement from people
satellites because this time that is
acquired at 12 bit in our ADC rate all
the previous ones with 8-bit and the
data is stored as 16-bit unions and if
you want to really drill into the data
and analyze it you know in fine detail
you will have to know look from time to
time in this file just
right your routines - no go pick up but
you exactly need from that and there's
also another you know folder in that on
another file not folder in that zipped
file you download it's been delaying its
quality band and that quality band is
very helpful because it you know the
data that you get is not really raw it's
already pre processed by some stations
that are taking care of that and if I
scroll further down you'll see that as
you read this you know you know bytes
from from this quality band you can only
be guessed or not yes they tell you what
was wrong with this you know particular
pixel that you're getting so you can see
that you know if you get value six you
know the first one cloud yes knows no
eyes and so and so forth
and you can go to matte box blog this is
the company that is trying to
commercialize all this date and they
have great blog which is really
down-to-earth you don't have to be a
scientist or and you know analyst to to
you know know what's going on there so
let's make our first image yes
yes I haven't uploaded them all because
as you can see nothing is annotated so
once it's annotated go to my github
repos and it will be there yeah and also
for data you have to register download
on your own because yeah yeah so for
this I'll be using the you know psychic
image that's all you need you know plus
Python so let's start and see if this
demo will go so what I'm not trying but
what I'm doing is just reading in the
RGB bands that we you know need for
making pretty pictures and while this is
going on if you want to analyze in my
experience that the best thing to do is
do it in a Linux machine it's the least
trouble
OS that's why aka Yosemite is fine but
there is a little of hiccups because I
think SK learn can have trouble reading
the you know unsigned you know 16-bit
integers so you can change the plug-in
that's you know going on it can complain
because you know these tip images are
geotubes
they have all these geo you know tags
included in Lego active files but if you
if you see all the warnings don't for
your body it will within the the
imitator
but the J data will be discarded which
should hang at this step we don't really
care
and this is our you know RGB image and I
was saying what the hell is this it's
like completely dark and the thing is
these instruments are calibrated to
acquire data from really dark
backgrounds oceans are you know but look
look down from the sky they're really
dark and they have to have a wide range
so from dark portions all the way to you
know white snow caps on mountains and
for this we need to you know adjust our
exposure so this is basically stretching
this range that was not used for
acquiring image and kind of brightening
our image first so we'll do two things
will brighten our image and we'll adjust
its contrast and now you can see here
this is the distribution of our you know
RGB and I intentionally I mean if you
try to if you see here I left out the
not the first column because it's all
the black pixels which are those
triangles so those skew how your
histogram looks so this is your date and
you can see that only a small portion of
what's available to you is being used
for distributing this so the next thing
we want to do is kind of stretch this
across this axis so we are utilizing
that the full width of you know range
that we have at our disposal
okay now this is now looking up let's
move further down and I think he will
plot how the new distribution looks like
and now you can see that you know we
really stretched our pixels throughout
the full range and we probably like over
blue certain pixels because they go all
the way up to one now this is kind of an
iterative process you know you got try
one thing it doesn't work you you know
move your limits left and right until
you find the the right Ranger this is
just a question of you know experience
and you know trial and error it's a
valid scientific approach right so now
that you know stretch that basically
brighten our image we need to adjust the
contrast and for this contrast
adjustment there's a range of function
so we'll use a simple exponential
function to adjust this contrast and you
can you know play again it's playing
around and you don't have only the
exponential function at your disposal
you can use sigmoidal functions so in
this case you know you can choose do I
want to emphasize my highlights my low
lights or do you want to stretch you
like mid-range so let's do this
okay now we have an image that looks
pretty decent
maybe you know here certain things now
this is guinea-bissau
it's on the west coast of Africa and
here is that the islands surrounding the
the river that's running its river Gabe
I think you can see that we probably you
know the live is not really wide so
those are the white pixels that we
really blew out and you can probably go
back but this is fine enough if you go
and check out how image specialists are
doing with you know the same image you
can see that you know they've done
pretty much the same thing that you know
we accomplished with you know a few
ipython cell executions now at this
point if this luminary from you know
History Channel comes up you know I'll
be talking aliens right yes when I say
aliens I mean crop circles so these are
actual crops in the form of circles
right this is a shot of I think it's in
Kansas like southwest of Dodge and you
can see all these bright circles we use
that you know one particular band I told
you that's will go to distinguishing the
crops the near-infrared and why are
these perfect circles or maybe like you
know oh it's beauty why are over there
its I didn't know about that it's called
pivot central pivot irrigation systems
and these systems you know can make and
grow crops around the year and these
things are big each of four of these
circles is one mile square and these
guys are running this around the pod
basically you know you can be growing
crops now not really year around but
stretch what would usually be a normal
period of here to grow
and this is also important because this
is kind of the tail end of one of the
biggest aquifers of garlic for fire and
that stretches all the way from I think
North the product on the way to Texas
and because of the advanced agriculture
and you know basically what we're using
a resource use certain parts of this
aquifers are drying out and it's very
important to to monitor this stuff
because all the satellite imagery is
being used for types of data that you
know truly associate is not exciting
like I want to show people you know
what's going wrong so agriculture but
you know everybody has to eat right I
mean we did all these metals because you
know believe it or not one day we will
run out of copper maybe you know there's
no copper there's no you know fancy Mac
machines you know to play around we'll
run out of oil oil industry is a big
industry that uses this what people do
that
and you know at this point where as I
was preparing this presentation I think
I was it was fifth hour or sitting in a
bus somewhere between Boston in New York
in a state which we call New Yorker
juices and I decided that you know
everybody has been it's certain proper
people in our show show you the stuff
that you've already seen or know how to
do and I want you know for you to
believe out with one simple thing to
know so I decided to skip what I said in
the episode that I will show you how to
do little image recognition so let's
count all these circles figure out what
the area was the yield of [ __ ] or what
not and then go back to that you know
TripIt acid image that that's a
compromise in Arizona and try to figure
out like you know how long do we have to
you know mind those minerals around but
you know usually you know we are kind of
drawn to data that you know
behind that so no telling you about this
he's maybe not as good as telling you
about what does that study tell hub you
know white people in Kansas a weird in
terms of use of the born hub website
right so I want you to go out with one
thing in mind and this is you know this
image analysis you know sampling your
data is really important and you know
when you sample your data you know you
can use maybe some sort of grid but
weeds are not good because you know they
have some periodicity and lots of signal
processing is not really good for you
know accounting for this periodicity you
can choose some sort of like random you
know picking of your pixels but each
randomness has you know certain things
that are really not what you're looking
for so I went back I remember if it was
this spring I remember seeing that
there's this guy Mike Bostock he has a
great website and he had their this you
know algorithm which if you read the
paper you know I think I kind of get it
what's going on there but if you go to
his website and have a look at how the
algorithm is actually doing he's great
so I want to show and also I thought
that you know I'd be able to Google this
somebody will have done this for Python
because this is all for d3 Mike Bostock
and Jason Davis who who came up with
this algorithm they have this available
for d3 but not for Python so like damn
it
there's no copy and paste programming
for me but luckily enough this is not
such a complicated algorithm so I'll
quickly show you how the algorithm
actually works so as you can see here we
pick a point at random everything that's
in a gray zone
it's an exclusion zone you cannot pick
another pixel it's in this gray zone you
can only pick a pixel that's in this
circle here now each peak
so that you ping that within this circle
has to be a certain prescribed distance
away from all other pixels and I you you
do this but by doing this but you doing
is picking random pixels but that are
only a certain distance away and you
iterate this until you know you come
back to each pixel and once you come
back for the second time to this pixel
you don't find available pixel for it
you mark it as black as you can see here
and you'll never come back to it again
and this is all nice and fine but let's
see how it works for Python so there you
go within like a second we have this you
know distribution as you can see here it
doesn't really look like random but it's
really random yes for two minutes
okay and while this important this image
here is randomly picking pixels in each
of the area is encoded as color and you
can see here we have a huge variation in
color right randomly picking pixels we
use this algorithm we have a really
uniform distribution of area between the
pixels and this is done by you know
constructing a Voronoi diagram so try to
do that for
it all looks nice and fine as you can
see here roller diagrams unfortunately
have this big slit at the edge that
instead to infinity and two you cannot
calculate there you know the infinitely
large area so if we now just concentrate
and really what's important here we get
you know what's really smooth and
uniform and now here are plotted the
distribution of area you can see most of
those pixels are within the certain
distribution and all this pixel sticking
out are those on the edges of the image
or so I thought
and let's see if I was right so I only
rearranged pixels here that they got
distorted out you can see most of them
are really the same range except that
those that are really shooting up now if
I exclude those you know high area
pixels you can really see that the
troublemakers are the pixels that are on
the outside edges and everything else is
fine now
this is where I stopped because I really
haven't found a good way to include
these pixels into the bigger picture I
think instead of using those faraway
points as an endpoint of our infinite
you know Verna ridges if I only limit
them to what's you know X and my limits
of our image I think this should be all
nice and fine and I plotted also the
distribution of the included areas you
can see that it's fairly uniform it
works
I trust Mike Buster because he's a
really good guy right so thank you for
your attention and if you have any
questions I'll gladly answer